you've grown yourself like a whole new
career out of his experience you raised
the bar in motion capturing like no one
else did what are you going to do with
it in the future performance capture is
it's got an incredible future and it is
a marriage of performance but it's also
that this incredible artistry and and
also the heritage of of artists too and
a culture because I realize actually
coming back to the UK and working with
other visual effects company then in
fact whehter really have developed the
most extraordinary singular pipeline in
terms of transferring an actor's
performance into it into an avatar
character and that is something that can
be learned all all around the world now
to the degree I mean it is literally
people who have not not only they're
creating software and technology but
it's idiots artistry it's in its the way
that the performances are interpolated
and transferred from from the the you
know what is created on set so but I
mean Pete's quite right I mean the for
instance just to answer your question
personally I mean I'm directing Jungle
Book at the moment and if you know we
are creating quadropod animals literally
people say well you can't possibly be in
happy new back and Panthers and tigers
and you know how can they possibly be
played by humans but in the same way
that's small and benedict doing its
extraordinary job of giving life and
soul and personality to you know 150
foot dragon you know where we're trying
to find we're trying to break through in
terms of technology that will all
methodology rather that will help us
break through into into finding the how
we're going to anthropomorphize how
we're going to humanize these animal
characters so so you find the tools that
are necessary for each for each other or
whether it's addressing anything you
just you just but you know talking about
the technology but the and the
technology you can create the technology
to make these things happen but it's the
actor that provides a soul you use the
word soul and the technology I ain't
going to provide the soul that that's
where the performance capture captures
the it captures the soul of the of the
actor that that's what that's what it's
great great age well I think I think
that's why it is such an extraordinary
combination really because it is like
that what the visual effects team do the
way that they amplify the the the likes
of characters you know like small gore
golem or all of those things is is what
is revolutionary it's that you do have
that human connection
you can sense the the emotion you all of
the choices that the actor makes on the
set with the other actors all of that
that you could never previously have the
other actors imagine is there for free
because it's real it's happening it's
chemical and it and it's vibrant and and
that is what is lifted and and then and
transfer onto onto these avatar
characters and that's that's why it is a
beautiful storytelling tool in a really
liberating tool for for 21st century
acting
you